[Music]
everyone knows the story of The Lion
King or do they there's a lot of
evidence that scar isn't actually Mufasa
's brother keep watching to find out if
scar and Mufasa are really related or if
scars just some vengeful lion who wants
to be king the controversy if you asked
just about anyone to tell you the story
of The Lion King they would say pretty
much the same thing Mufasa as the king
of the Lions and he has a son named
Simba
but mufasa's evil brother scar wants to
rule scar kills Mufasa and Simba runs
off into the jungle he grows up with a
meerkat and a warthog before he returns
to his pride and becomes king
[Music]
but back in 2017 the producer of The
Lion King dropped a bombshell that left
us sug Don Han revealed that scar and
Mufasa aren't brothers scar Mufasa we're
not brothers but they are they I just
want to clear that up just in case they
said that it would just not be possible
with the way Lions work in the wild this
changes the whole story
if scar is just some random lion who
wants to take over why does Mufasa call
him brother why does everyone think he's
Simba's uncle then things got even more
confusing just a few days later the
director of The Lion King chimed in Rob
Minkoff said that scarred Mufasa are
definitely brothers he wanted to clear
up any confusion but now we're just even
more confused who do we listen to the
producer or the director we decided to
figure it out for ourselves here are the
signs that Mufasa and scar aren't
related why isn't my big brother
descending from on high to go with the
commas
that's not how pride to work the first
reason we think scar and Mufasa aren't
brothers has everything to do with the
way lion prides happen lions are very
territorial especially the males lion
prides very rarely have two male lions
there is usually just one adult male see
male lions don't get along very well
when a male lion cub grows up he goes
out on his own sometimes an outside male
lion will try to take over the pride
just like scar does he challenges the
reigning lion to a fight if he wins he
gets to take over he becomes the male to
all the female lions it's pretty brutal
occasionally a pride will have two male
lions but they are never related if we
follow the laws of lions than scar
Mufasa can't be brothers of course this
is just a movie Lions also don't have
birth celebrations where a monkey paints
the baby lions head we had to look for
more evidence that scar is not part of
the family
it's just genetics don't worry we're not
gonna give you a science lesson on
genetics let's look the obvious fact
Mufasa and scar looked nothing alike
Mufasa has a golden coat red mane and
yellow shiz scar has a darker brown coat
his mane is black and his eyes are green
if they do have the same parents how do
they look so different they have totally
different accents too it's just not
believable that they are brothers when
he put them side-by-side siblings might
not always be identical but they usually
look at least a little related scar and
Mufasa don't scar confirms it it's a
subtle line that he probably missed but
scar essentially confirms that he isn't
related to Mufasa
when Mufasa comes to chew him out for
not being at Simba's coronation scar
says that he is from the shallow end of
the gene pool
I'm afraid I'm at the shallow end of the
gene its Cardon fossa are brothers they
would be from the same part of the gene
pool so why does scar say he's from a
different part it's just because he
knows that he isn't related to Mufasa
they were never meant to be brothers
movie scripts undergo a lot of changes
before the final version is released and
the Lion King changed a lot before they
decided on the version we know and love
for instance Mufasa wasn't going to be
seen after the Stampede but they decided
that somebody needed visions of him or
he would have no reason to return to
Pride Rock another major change had to
do a scar he was not supposed to be
related to Mufasa at all he was
originally just a lone lion who's
jealous of Mufasa
he thought Mufasa was lucky and he
wanted his own pride so he came in to
challenge from fossa and take control
this is pretty much how things actually
happen in the wild it was only in the
final version of the script that they
made scar the brother Mufasa
but scar doesn't live with the other
lions in the pride he continues to be an
outsider if he was related to Mufasa
wouldn't he be around more he doesn't
even associate with lions he hangs out
with hyenas instead just because my
father calls him brother doesn't mean
that these two are literally related the
creator's never meant for them to be
brothers and it shows we are super
excited to see the CGI remake of The
Lion King take scars advice and be
prepared to find out the truth about
scar and Mufasa and we want to know if
scar Mufasa is relationship will be
addressed at all will they continue to
be seen as brothers if so we hope that
director and writers clear up a lot of
confusion or will they make scar an
outsider like you
originally intended to be since we can't
get a straight answer from the creators
of the 1994 version it's up to you to
decide do you think with awesome scar
our brothers or is there just too much
evidence that they aren't related at all
do you think there will be any other
changes in the new movie don't be shy
let us know all your fan theories in the
comment section thanks for watching the
things if you liked this video give us a
big thumbs up and hit that subscribe
button see you next time
[Music]